is this is this  offers the repetition and it's  the second time we've seen this position  now right yeah and uh magnus is going to  move his rook back where it came from  here we go there we go and jan if he  wants the draw which i think he does  um then he's just going to step back  with the white rook continue challenging  the black rook and some faces before  yeah  it wouldn't be and if there weren't some  grimaces and there weren't some uh faces  along the way  but  uh yeah magnus looking comfortable as  well there's no reason to repeat the  position twice as well after move 40  when you've made the time control so  um yeah it looks like he's ready  he's about to allow the draw to happen  yeah magnus definitely looks ready here  it  goes yeah  and there it is magnus  makes the move okay they do offer a draw  and there we go interesting interesting  all right we do have game five in dubai  a draw another draw they are still tied  these two with nine games now to go will  we